الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
يعني
من قلب افريقيا الى فرنسا خط جغرافي
يتجاوز طوله ثلاثه الاف كيلومتر ورغم هذه
المسافه البعيده تطغى اللغه الفرنسيه على
السنه سكان هذا البلد هنا النيجر
ما قصه النفوذ الفرنسيه الممتد لعقود
طويله وما سر الاهتمام الاوروبي بهذا
البلد ولماذا تحول الانقلاب في النيجر من
صراع محلي الى مواجهه صامته بين فرنسا
وروسيا
يبلغ عدد سكان النيجر 24 مليون نسمه
اغلبيتهم الساحقه مسلمون حدود النيجر بريه
بالكامل ولا يحدها اي بحر ويخترق اراضيها
نهر النيجر الذي اخذت اسمها منه وقعت عين
فرنسا على هذه الارض في اواخر القرن
التاسع عشر وفي عام
1922 اصبح اسمها مستعمره النيجر لتخضعها
لحكم باريس بالكامل تغير الحال جزئيا مع
انتخاب جمعيه اقليميه بالتصويت الشعبي عام
1956 لتمنح سلطات استشاريه واداريه فقط في
اعقاب الحرب الجزائريه وانهيار الجمهوريه
الفرنسيه الرابعه اعلنت النيجر استقلالها
في الثامن من نوفمبر تشرين الثاني عام
1960 استقلال اتاح للبلاد دستورا وعلما
وسياده في المحافل الدوليه لكنه لم يخلص
النيجر من اثر العامر القديم على غرار دول
افريقيه عده ولان النيجر ليست مثل غيرها
من المحيط الافريقي فقد حظيت باهتمام بالغ
من الفرنسيين ويعود ذلك الى الثروات
الكثيره التي تمتلكها فهي رابع اكبر منتج
لليورانيوم في العالم وبدات الشركه
النوويه الفرنسيه بتعدين احتياطات
اليورانيوم في النيجر منذ عام
1970 لتوفير ما يصل الى
35% من احتياجات المفاعلات النوويه
الفرنسيه من اليورانيوم كما تمتلك البلاد
ثروات اخرى بينها معادن متنوعه والنفط
ومناجم ذهب هذه الثروات التي اصبحت نعمه
على الغرباء ونقمه على سكان الارض
ففي عام 2020 لم تتجاوز مساهمه ثروات
النيجر في الميزانيه الوطنيه اكثر من 1.2%
وفي عام 2021 زودت النيجر الاتحاد
الاوروبي بما يقرب من 25% من امدادات
اليورانيوم وهو ما ساعد على انتاج
الكهرباء لملايين الاسر بعد ازمه كورونا
وهو العام نفسه الذي شهد اغلاق مناجم
بالقرب من بلده ارليت الشماليه ليترك سكان
مئات القرى مهددين باشعاعات 20 مليون طن
من المواد النوويه في موقع منجم
تحتل النيجر المرتبه الاخيره في مؤشر
التنميه البشريه واكثر من نصف سكانها تحت
خط الفقر مع نسبه 50% من الاطفال في سن
التعليم غير مقيدين في المدارس على مدى
عقود حاولت النيجر تخفيف تبعيتها للمستعمر
القديم في عام 2006 اقرت قانون المناجم
لزياده الضرائب على المعادن المستخرجه من
خمسه فاصله خمسه بالمئه الى 12 بالمئه مع
الغاء بعض الاعفاءات الضريبيه لكن هذه
المحاولات لا تدعمها ارضيه سياسيه صلبه
فالنيجر شهدت منذ الاستقلال اربعه
انقلابات ناجحه وعده محاولات فاشله
للاستيلاء على السلطه وفي انقلاب يوليو
تموز من عام 2023 تتجلى صوره الصراع
الدولي على هذا البلد الافريقي الذي قلم
عرف السلام والديمقراطيه هنا تحرق رايات
فرنسا في احتجاجات مناهضه للرئيس محمد
بازوم المتهم بالتقرب من باريس وفي
المظاهره نفسها ترفع اعلام روسيا المتهمه
ايضا بدعم قيادات في الجيش لتدبير
الانقلاب قد يطوى عهد فرنسا لكن مكانها
ستحل روسيا القادمه من بعيد وعينها على
الثروات والنفوذ والثقل السياسي لهذه
القاره وتحمل معها بالمقابل الكثير من
اوراق القوه صفقات اسلحه حبوب والاهم
حمايه حلفائها من القاده فيما بات عرفا في
افريقيا بان من يتحالف مع روسيا لا تهددهم
انقلابات تحفه